let's talk to cosmetic surgery advisor
Cindy Jackson good morning it's part of
the issue here that people aren't seeing
this is a proper procedure the thing
that they're seeing it just is a simple
injection therefore you know they don't
worry about the regulation in the same
way
I think it's multifactorial I mean
there's a recession on so people try to
save money they do see people in the
press with massive lips and they think
it's a good look and also some people
who are injecting some of these
practitioners they make money per vial
so the more they inject the more they
get paid and they might be saying to
their patient you know it looks great
let's have more and sometimes people do
think a little bit is good so a more
might be better but in a lot of cases
they end up with the child pout lips
full of filler and it's not a good look
but people are making a profit and when
it in facts they have real problems I
have clients coming to me with in
massive infections and some of them are
very very difficult to treat and it
costs the NHS untold thousands to I'll
put it right but the wider problem is
that that people seem to be looking at
it as an extension of their beauty
regime rather than that the medical
procedure that in effect it is it's kind
of half and a half it's not a necessary
medical procedure but yes it needs to be
taken seriously as something you're
doing to your body which needs to be
done by a properly qualified
professional under sterile circumstances
who keep the people who keep the
products sterile under proper conditions
so not to spread infections so yes it
really is something to be taken
seriously but it's not necessary to have
it done people want it done because they
want to look better but when you go to
demand some of them beauty can be
enhanced with with these products but it
can also go the other direction if it's
overdone or if it's done with products
that are not meant to be injected into
the face I mean what we're talking we
are talking about something going under
the skin and particular with it was
something like a lip line you've got a
you've got to have someone who really
understands presumably you know the
physical structure in
to get this in safety exactly well I've
had my lips done I haven't done off and
on I only go to a an experienced surgeon
who understands the anatomy underneath
the skin and also is much more likely to
be scrupulous about preventing infection
keeping everything sterile which is
extremely important when you're
injecting anything into the body would
that be your advice then not to go to
anyone unless they had a medical
background absolutely I mean it is it's
you've only got one body one face and if
you mess it up and you start injecting
mystery products which happens so much
you wouldn't believe people come to me
and say look what's happened in my face
the injections went all wrong my first
question is what what did they put in
you would not believe how many people
say they have no idea what was even
injected so people need to become more
aware patients and and ladies who want
to look better regulation is is very
very important but raising awareness is
even more important and that's part of
my job it's a major part of what I do I
mean some some patients go abroad to non
EU countries and get injected with
god-knows-what
yeah and then they they come back and
and then they need help and they all the
regulation in the UK isn't going to
change that because they haven't had it
done in the UK but the UK NHS has to put
it right deal with it Cindy appreciate
your time miss Warren thanks very much
indeed think about it very carefully
seems to be the message there and don't
go cheap do it properly